sunrises in southwestern Kenya after
their morning drive at all King a
Conservancy Pauline and Noelle gently
settle down for breakfast in the wild
this is the last day of Safari for the
couple from New Zealand the highlight
here with the camp is the food and we're
going camping so we're taking picnic
breakfast with us and so it's all packed
ready for us we go up we found a lovely
location we sit there on the other side
of the camp
Simon cuicci and his team of Rangers
keep watch Simon has worked as a senior
warden for three and a half years now
but still has to convince the locals
that protecting the environment is
important when I talk about
environmental security so that people
don't cut trees down
don't cause fires and wildlife you know
so that they become the word dose of on
behalf of the community and in behalf of
the government the same one benefits
from the partnership between locals and
to safari companies in this partnership
members of the neighbouring masse
community leads out more than 7,500 big
chairs of land to the safari companies
they receive a monthly payment depending
on the number of acres they have leased
when land was divided into individual
land ownership then people together Kim
and Anna sign lease with the company in
order to form a Conservancy people now
are more settled and now they will not
move mainly their livestock because you
know they have they have more other land
outside the Conservancy and they get
money from the Conservancy so their
grantee income and they are happy today
they are almost 200 land owners leasing
their land which makes a big difference
the area now has over 20 lions
as well as cheetahs leopards a host of
birds gazelles kept buffaloes and many
others in addition to the income from
leasing their land the community also
offers activities for the tourists local
residents have also set up enclosures to
protect their livestock from wild
animals they call them lion boma can't
it Olli Perot and his son aquapyro have
one they have over 500 animals some
money in the past who used to have a lot
of problems with wild animals attacking
our livestock would attack and kill our
cows and goats but since we go to the
boma there are no limits Orion is
attacking our animals in a part of CyBC
a bomb
but not everything is rosy having fenced
in enclosures within the protected area
poses a problem as the Senior Warden
explains several problem caused by the
fences one it blocks the wildlife
corridor their normal migratory route
that is one of the challenge secondly it
traps a wildlife when they try to jump
over they are entangled
inside the fences that cause conflict
the Conservancy management argues that
the government needs to engage more with
locals by providing compensation for
attacks on their livestock and more
suitable protection measures if the
locals care for the wild animals they
will attract more tourists like the ones
from New Zealand and in the end everyone
will benefit locals the tourists the
wildlife and
Battlement
[Music]